tiêu đề nó khá là khác khá là lạ đúng
không ạ Hôm nay mình sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn về
thực ra Đáng lẽ buổi Thứ bảy này nhưng
mình nói thì sẽ là buổi chấm đồ án nhưng
mà
nhưng mà mình nghĩ là mình sẽ phải chữa
cái này sớm cho các nhóm mà thực ra các
nhóm đều chủ yếu thì đang làm đồ án liên
quan đến bên học viện hay bên quản lý gì
gì đó Nói chung bài toán nghiệp vụ thì
Hôm nay tôi sẽ làm cái bài toán thử Giả
sử một cái bài toán nghiệp vụ là điểm
danh là cái khó nhất
thì hi vọng là chữa xong thì các bạn
thực ra là các bạn Có code thì cũng
trường hợp này chắc là tôi chỉ có demo
rồi tôi không chia sẻ code mấy ông tự
làm lại thôi nhưng mấy ông có phải hiểu
giải quyết bài toán là như thế nào Ừ nhỉ
Có vài nhóm mà tôi bảo là chữa cho đồ án
nhóm nhóm các bạn nhỉ
tội nhưng mà tôi quen sử mất là nhóm Ông
làm về cái gì rồi
giống cái điểm danh thôi điểm điểm danh
điểm thực ra dễ hơn điểm danh đấy nhưng
mà nói chung là hôm nay tôi sẽ chữa cho
mấy ông hẳn điểm danh luôn thì mấy ông
sẽ hiểu được bài toán nó sẽ như nào thì
đầu tiên thì bởi tôi hình dung Tôi làm
từng làm rồi chứ nếu không là tôi yêu
cầu mấy ông vẫn phải vẽ ra cái vẽ ra cái
điểm mấy ông hiểu được là cần phải làm
gì mà đúng không Thì tôi nhớ là tôi từng
cho mấy ông xem cái phần mềm của tôi rồi
danh nó sẽ kiểu trông như thế nào rồi
đúng không ạ
này à chọn môn này rồi chọn lợn các lớp
hồi đấy mình làm cho kiểu các lớp kiểu
Giả sử là có thể có thể kiểu dậy hai lớp
cùng một lúc kiểu như này nó sẽ hiển thị
ra là toàn bộ sinh viên của hai lớp đấy
Kiểu như này sau đó thì mình mặc định là
mình sẽ tích hết và đi học có thể tích
vào nghỉ muộn hay cái gì gì đó hiển thị
ở buổi trước là như nào chẳng hạn thế
tổng số giờ dậy đã dậy lớp đấy số giờ
còn lại dạy lớp đấy Vân tình trạng đi
học của lớp đấy đã điểm danh hay chưa số
buổi đã dậy lớp đấy là như thế nào
đến cuối này sẽ nhập số giờ vào sau đó
thì ghi chú có thể cho ấn cập nhật khi
mà ấn cập nhật xong đây giả sử như này
khi ấn cập nhật xong thì sẽ xuất ra được
là có bao nhiêu người đang nghỉ có phép
hay gì đó vân vân và
cái này mà tôi sẽ chỉ demo cho mấy ông
thì mấy ông có thể hiểu được bài toán để
làm thôi ok nhé bắt đầu nhỉ
thì đầu tiên là mình sẽ có database đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ sẽ tạo một data bay mới
đi
rồi không phải đến điểm danh mới dùng
mấy ông bị lạm dụng choi quá cho nhiều
không tốt
viện đúng không ạ giả sử như này
sau đó thì mình sẽ lưu ở đây một cái là
học viện
đây là học viện
xếp ở lại
mình bản chất là mình sẽ tạo ra dâu tây
là mình sẽ có bảng đương nhiên có bảng
liệu nhiều bảng không
Tại sao lại delete dữ liệu nhiều bảng
nhỉ Ông định làm gì
hạn chế Delete dữ liệu thôi
sinh viên đúng không ạ tạm bỏ qua bằng
khóa đi bởi vì thực tế là vừa rồi Khi mà
mình dậy thì mình dậy không giáo viên
không dạy liên quan đến à kiểu dạng
không chọn khóa đâu mà gần như là chọn
mấy ông thấy vừa rồi tôi chọn là chọn
lớp với môn đúng không ạ lớp à môn rồi
lớp hoặc là lớp môn tùy nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là môn này lớp cũng rất là hay để
mà kiểu đương nhiên cái đấy là dựa trên
cả bảng phân công nữa nhưng mà giả sử
bây giờ mình mình đang chưa có bảng phân
công đi À không nghĩa là bây giờ thực tế
là kiểu bây giờ coi như là
mấy ông sẽ phải tự làm cái phân công đi
bây giờ chỉ nốt cả mấy ông về cái phân
công cho tôi làm hết sự Cái đồ án của
mấy ông mất rồi thì
coi như là bây giờ có môn này có lớp này
sau khi chọn lớp thì tất cả sinh viên
của lớp đấy này đúng không ạ sau đó thì
mình sẽ lưu lại mình sẽ điểm danh cho
tất cả sinh viên đấy để lưu lại vào điểm
danh và điểm danh chi tiết đấy mình sẽ
có những cái tư thế sẽ có bao nhiêu Bảng
nhỉ và 5 bảng mình cũng sẽ có 5 bảng ok
chưa
đến đoạn này mấy ông bắt kịp được chứ
trạng quan trọng lắm Xóa đi cũng được
hoặc là tạo thành cái mới đi Tôi nghĩ
tạo hẳn cái mới
Ariel news mới là được
mình sẽ có 3 năm bảng đúng không ạ
Bạn
điểm danh và điểm danh chi tiết
lớp này mã môn này nhưng mà ở
mấy ông vừa rồi Thế là chọn à
đúng không ạ tôi còn lưu lại các lớp ở
đây là các mã lớp bởi vì ở Hồi đấy tôi
chấm công là giả sử là hạ giáo viên điểm
danh cho hai lớp cùng một lúc nhưng mà
chỉ được tính chấm công là 11 Lớp thôi
thành ra mới phải làm thế Còn nếu mấy
ông Muốn tách ra cũng được theo kiểu là
tuy là điểm danh 2 lớp nhưng mà được
chấm công hai lần thì sẽ tách ra còn nếu
mà không thì sẽ phải lưu lại các lớp ở
trong này để hiểu được là là một lúc
mình dậy nhiều lớp
mã giáo viên nữa nhưng mà tôi bảo tôi
tạm bỏ qua Vụ này mình sẽ có ngày giờ
bắt đầu rơi kết thúc đúng không ạ
nhiều người thì bảo làm theo ca đúng
không ạ Cũng được
mình sẽ mình có thể làm với cả cũng được
cho đơn giản
ngày ca và mã lớp nó sẽ là kiểu nên là
unic nghĩa âm Chỉ là kiểu là trong cùng
ngày trong cùng ca thì cái lớp đấy nó
chỉ học một môn thôi đúng không ạ Đấy
tiếp theo mình sẽ có điểm danh chi tiết
mình sẽ có mã điểm danh và mã sinh viên
và tình trạng đi học
đấy tình trạng đi học cụ thể là gì đấy
ví dụ là kiểu Hồi đấy tôi cho quy ước là
kiểu Nếu giả sử là đi muộn thì sẽ tính
bằng
1/3 buổi nghỉ thế 3 lần đi muộn rồi tính
bằng một buổi nghỉ đấy Kiểu như thế thì
và nghỉ nhiều quá quá ví dụ 20% số buổi
thì không được thi kiểu thế
Ok Bây giờ mình sẽ làm
thì tôi sẽ chạy bằng cái này đi
[âm nhạc]
Microsoft đúng không ạ Mình sẽ tạo 53
ra không cần tạo Cần Thơ
tiên là mình sẽ có
lớp đúng không là class nhưng mà rõ ràng
thì nếu thấy khó chịu với class theo
kiểu gọi là là cậu nó nó kiểu bị trùng
tên ý tôi sẽ đặt nó code kiểu này khóa
đi mà sẽ mua độ sẽ là maration
đó mình sẽ tạo trước cái này
À quên phải tạo cho nó nữa
không dùng đến nhé
mình sẽ có cột là cột nêm là xong
Tạo shipper như thế Tôi vứt hết tôi sẽ
xử lý luôn Ở ngay trong này một cái ship
đồ vậy không cần phải tạo cái Factory
nữa
đồ ăn mấy ông phải xem cái video này này
bây giờ video quan trọng này mấy ông cần
phải xem thì mấy ông hiểu được cách làm
làm gì có Factory mà yêu mình sẽ có là
tiếp theo mình sẽ tạo student
subject
là môn học
điểm danh là
được
Để mình hiểu được là nó là trung gian
giữa hai thằng nó kiểu pipe nó là thằng
bạn trung gian giữa hai thằng cũng được
danh chi tiết dịch ra điểm danh chi tiết
điểm danh sinh viên ở điểm danh sinh
viên không đến nỗi tớ sẽ tạo kiểu này đi
đó Nói chung là sẽ có rất nhiều bạn đúng
không ạ
string này
khác của student nhá mình sẽ có table và
fouryki luôn này
là cho đến ta có
Em lấy ra nhiều thì em nên cách thôi
ít thay đổi Mình thích nó lại để mình đỡ
làm mất công truy vấn liên tục vào nó
và có thể liên quan đến cả config các
thứ thường config thường là bên giao
diện là nhiều
có thể kích lại được mình thường xuyên
dùng với nó
nha Xem đổ rượu nhé
lỗi luôn
cái này sẽ là database
xóa cái kia rồi
robot
Mình chưa mình chưa chạy cái probas
đợi chạy luôn cả mấy cái kia không lên
mình sẽ có bạn ở đây sẽ có table
lười
chuẩn ra mấy ông sẽ còn phải thêm những
cái tính các thứ thứ nó nữa
mình đây mình sẽ có đến cái đoạn quan
trọng này
sắp trái cây đi này
Nó là tên là Dead luôn cũng được không
sao
sẽ để
với cosx
cái cùng bị chung ông có thể kiểu đặt
tên cho con chết này cũng được Còn không
thì nó nó sẽ tạo mặc định cho cái con
chết này con gì nha ôi chắc thế thôi
tiếp theo mình sẽ có bảng này
sẽ có
không có cột ID không có time sẽ thẳng
luôn là
một cái là standing
tình trạng đi học thì mình sẽ đặt tên nó
status cũng được có thể đơn giản như thế
sau đó mình sẽ quy ước cái kiểu một là
gì Hai gì bằng i5 sao
học nhưng mà có ở đây Tôi đang để nó là
chính là lớp nó class đấy bởi vì nếu
mình đặt tên nó class thì thì nó sẽ bị
lỗi vì không được chứ chưa Cái từ đấy
ông hình dung không class không thể đặt
tên nó thành mua đồ được nên là tôi đặt
tên nó thế thôi
kiểu khóa khóa học ấy
khóa chính chỉnh chính là
ID và toda
theo mình Bây giờ mình bắt đầu lần lượt
thêm và các bạn này đương nhiên là tôi
sẽ demo thêm trước vào trong bảng code
bảng Today
là mình
ôi thưởng hay làm cách tôi thường hay
làm ấy thì mình sẽ Đương nhiên mình fake
data đúng không ạ Tôi nhớ không lầm là
hình như là label bắt đầu có cái Faker
là là headp thì phải thằng này có chưa
nhỉ
đúng chưa
biết được không
đúng không
Để chạy thử
thằng kia là mình sẽ phải khai báo
mà
bây giờ mình sẽ có đầu tiên là
ghost này
thêm vào trong cái mạng này
truyền nêm vào đúng không
anh sẽ là Faker gọi đến cái gì mình sẽ ở
đây có những cái gì nhỉ
có cả vụ gì nhỉ
muốn học cũng có nhớ ở đấy có cả môn học
một lát Ngô thôi đúng không Ok
mình sẽ có code đây
khác đi
không
cos này Thực ra thực tế thực tế là ông
không cần truyền phiêu bôi bổ nếu mà ông
chạy hàng in search về nó sẽ in sốt hàng
vào Không không cái thằng rết nó mới gọi
đến thằng à
quên hoặc là khi mà ông khởi tạo đối
tượng cho Ông Sếp nó lại thì nó mới gọi
đến thằng Phil ơible
Còn khi mà Insert này thì nó sẽ in xuất
hẳn đâu luôn không cần gọi kiểu kia nữa
Ở đây khi mà in xuất xong Asus sinh viên
này tôi muốn là mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ
toàn bộ
code này lấy lại đã mình sẽ lắp
ra ID kiểu biên như này
nhiên trong trong cái danh sách này
mạc kia đấy
em ạ mạng danh sách toàn bộ chữ ID toàn
bộ khoa học đúng không ạ Cái này sẽ đơn
giản là Faker này sẽ lên thôi
đến 1000 đi
nó sẽ ngẫu nhiên ở trong 10 lớp Thực ra
tôi nghĩ năm lớp thôi năm lớp 10 môn 5
môn thôi năm lớp
không à năm lớp này 5 môn
1000 sinh viên
hơi nhiều quá 100 sinh viên thì đã là
mỗi lớp tầm 20 sinh viên nếu trong
trường hợp random này chuẩn
nó sẽ ngẫu nhiên mà
là 4 lỗi
báo lỗi cái code xe đi này
lỗi lỗi tôi nó là khi gọi thằng kia nó
sẽ trả về có thể không thì mình sẽ phải
là ở cos Tại thằng thứ không cơ
cái này chả phải chi mà
chồng có vẻ hơi khó hiểu một tí nhé
thực ra mình sẽ chạy kiểu robot cũng
được robot là nó cũng sẽ
xác nó không có hàm để mà để mà xóa toàn
bộ xóa toàn bộ đi kiểu xóa hết đi mà nó
chỉ có kiểu
cross là xóa hết thì phải
rồi trả lại shit này
Ok đúng không Đấy Bây giờ mình có người
này sinh viên ngẫu nhiên lớp học bây giờ
mình sẽ làm cái giao diện làm nhanh qua
giao diện kiểu để mà kiểu mà chọn lớp
này chọn môn này đúng rồi chọn lớp chọn
môn này toàn bộ sinh viên của lớp đấy
Sau đó thì mặc định là lúc đầu chưa có
điểm danh thì sẽ hiển thị ra như thế nào
xong rồi có điểm danh sẽ hiển thị lại
như nào
Trailer này nhé Có một thằng câu trả lời
nhé
đầu tiên khi vào đây này Nó sẽ trả về
cho mình một cái mình sẽ gọi đến
Chẳng hạn đơn giản này đi
Chính xác là chính xác là khi là chọn
lớp chọn môn thì sẽ
sẽ kiểu
mình mình sẽ phải kiểu có một cái form
Ấn Nút ấn nút gì gì đó nếu mà không dùng
ryuri Giả sử Bây giờ tôi không can thiệp
một tí regular
không dùng là Jack Siri gì cả thì đúng
là kiểu mình sẽ phải load lại trang để
mà kiểu hiển thị ra toàn bộ sinh viên
Tôi sẽ đặt tên đẹp phone đi
thị ra toàn bộ lớp và môn của thằng này
có thể chọn này có bằng cos
chết
view ở đây là hình như ở đây có một cái
webcam vừa phải
sáng nay đi này
index.
có
Ok này
mình sẽ mình sẽ có cái form để mình chọn
lớp này
form này
chọn lớp
sẽ là select
và forex ở đây
không cái đoạn này chưa nỗi khó Chả có
gì khó cả chỉ có Shiper các thứ thử làm
nó diện vào đúng không
đúng không ạ tôi không làm một tí gì
giao diện đâu nha
Mình sẽ chọn mua này
ba cái giao diện
bản chất là mình sẽ mình có thể vẫn ở
trên cái trên cái giao diện này vẫn có
thể trên này nhưng mình sẽ truyền lên
cái này và khi trượt lên thì mình sẽ
nãy nói đó là chọn chỉ chọn một lớp thôi
Tôi đang làm theo bài toán dễ thì chọn
một lớp điểm danh một lớp cùng một lúc
còn nếu điểm danh 2 lớp cùng lúc thì bài
toán phức tạp hơn đúng không ạ thì nếu
mà khi mà mình đẩy lên kiểu này tôi để
nó mới thớt làm cái thớt đi thường là
như này không nên hiển thị trên thanh
địa chỉ như này và khi mới thớt là post
thì mình sẽ mình sẽ nhảy đến Index chẳng
hạn như này
đây là Index
chuyển request vào
hàng ngày
mình sẽ có code ID sẽ bằng dry Quest lấy
code như này
ID đúng không ạ Có cả sub ID nữa
cái nữa à hai cái nữa đó là à đâu ba cái
chứ Cốt xe đi này sắp trái cây đi và
student nữa mình sẽ chuyển tất cả mấy
cái đấy về nữa này sẽ có xe đi này
sắp trái ID này và student
Tại sao phải truyền thêm về cái này để
mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểm tra ở đây là nếu mà
kiểu nếu mà nó có nếu có nếu
có ID này
mình sẽ Selection
cũ thôi
tôi sẽ tải lại trang này
chọn
thằng thứ hai đúng không ạ môn thứ ba
đúng không ạ ấn vào
Cái này nó là chuỗi
Cái này là chuỗi xong rồi Bên này mình
so sánh 3 dấu bằng cái hình sai
sang đây cái ID này nó lại là số thành
ra nó sai kiểu dữ liệu đó mình không
thấy không Thực ra trong trường hợp này
Thực ra tôi không thích lắm Bởi vì À
nó là nó là một mình so sánh với hai dấu
bằng với một chuỗi thì đôi khi nó vẫn
đúng đôi khi nó vẫn đúng đấy thử nhé
với như này
vẫn sẽ đúng với chuỗi nào nó chum
không sao ok tiếp theo là đến cái đoạn
dưới này là nếu mà ít set Nếu mà có
student trả về
mình sẽ có thay đổi
khi mà chọn xong hết rồi mình sẽ có cái
bảng hiển thị ra đây này Ở tr này th này
ở mình sẽ có mã sinh viên này tên sinh
viên này và tình trạng đi học này
Ox ở đây
sedane
để chồng cái này
ok chưa sinh viên của lớp mẹ thôi đúng
không ạ Đấy
mình sẽ có order bằng 1 beat Bằng 100%
rất màu mè rất đẹp
nhớ lại đồ ăn một không
sinh viên chưa có gì bây giờ mình sẽ
điểm danh từng sinh viên này đúng không
ạ Mình sẽ tích tích ở đây nó sẽ là ô
kiểu ô kiểu
mình sẽ có cái form ôm toàn bộ Cái này
thì mình chỉ có một cái nút ở cuối là
nút kiểu điểm danh thôi chứ không phải
là mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểu
chỗ nhập từng sinh viên rồi ấn điểm danh
thủ công từng bạn ở đây không mình chỉ
có một nút ở cuối thôi đúng không
ok chưa và đây mình sẽ có một tất cả rất
nhiều cái input hai là checkbox và valu
giả sử ba lô là 1 sẽ là đi học alo là
tôi thích làm theo kiểu như này nếu mà
ông để kiểu như này nhé để kiểu như này
thì ông tích vào cái ông đôi khi ông bấm
vào cái chữ đi học nó khó hơn vào cái
này này à đây cái radio
leble nó lên kiểu bắt sự kiện nó pho
xong rồi ID đến hàng ngày nhưng mà chơi
kiểu này cũng là một cái mẹo Bấm vào chữ
label chữ như này được ok chưa Đấy Bây
giờ mình sẽ còn nêm cho nó nêm cho nó ở
đây phải tránh bởi vì đây vòng lặp nên
tránh thằng khác thì thường là mình sẽ
phải thông qua cả
từng thằng nó sẽ nó sẽ như này
student cho đến ID mấy ông đừng cố thừa
dấu cách trong như này trong này nha đôi
khi nó thành lỗi đấy
[âm nhạc]
hưởng gì cả đúng không ạ Còn nếu mà Mấy
ông không hề có cái đoạn này thì mấy ông
sẽ chỉ tích được một sinh viên thôi vì
nó cùng trùng nam mà
đúng chứ
có 2 này Sự là nghỉ này giả sử chỉ có
mỗi hai cái này thôi Giả sử có mỗi hai
ngày thôi làm bài toán nó dễ đi
học nghỉ đi học đúng không ạ Nếu giả sử
giống như vừa nãy tôi làm đó là kiểu mặc
định mặc định là
mặc định là kiểu tích đi học thì sao thì
cái này là mấy ông sẽ phải kiểm tra
trước là đã nếu có giá trị rồi thì ông
ấy tích vào cái này nó hơi phức tạp một
tí thì tôi sẽ nói nói sau Khi mà điểm
danh xong đã rồi tôi sẽ nói
tạm thời trước mắt thì mấy ông trông
kiểu như này đã tôi sẽ
enter xuống dòng mấy ông nhìn nó rõ này
nó dài đấy
Thậm chí tôi Giả sử Tôi thích mỗi Ba bạn
này thôi chẳng hạn thì thực tế là tôi sẽ
chỉ điểm danh 3 bạn đấy thôi Giả sử thế
đầu tiên mình sẽ có một cái nút ở cuối
đúng không ạ là giả sử là điểm danh đúng
không ạ mấy ông đi Nhớ là chúng ta sẽ
còn cái ca học nữa mình sẽ ở đây mình
mình sẽ cho là độ ca này mình sẽ có một
cái là input là thai là kiểu number dnd
chọn lớp chọn môn rồi giờ sử tôi điểm
danh cho mỗi 3 đoạn đầu cho dễ nhé đi
học nghỉ nghỉ Đúng không ngày càng một
này khi tôi ấn điểm danh ở đây thì cái
form này nó sẽ cần riêng form này thì
mình sẽ phải nhảy đến cái Action đến râu
một cái router khác để mà điểm danh lớp
này đúng không ạ Có thể đến chính thằng
này cũng được Nhưng mà nếu thế mình sẽ
phải truyền thêm một cái tham số gì đó
nữa để hiểu là mình sẽ không nhảy vào
thằng Index này nữa mà sẽ điểm danh cho
đấy gần gần như thế Tôi nghĩ tôi sẽ đẩy
ở đây một cái khác đi tôi sẽ là ở đây
cái đặt tên nó cũng được Em đừng
danh kiểu như này Thấy chưa tôi sẽ
chuyển đây
thực tế là ông cái form này này nó đã bị
Hơi sai một tí theo kiểu là
dùng chọn chọn như này nhưng người dùng
chọn sửa lớp khác như này cho người dùng
ấn nút điểm danh thì thực ra là người
dùng đang đang bị hiểu nhầm thực tế là
rõ ràng là cái danh sách này danh sách
của cái lớp ở trên này danh sách mà mình
vừa chọn lại đúng không ạ nghĩa là mình
sẽ gần như là đôi khi không hiển thị là
cái này hoặc là Hiển thị cái này ở trang
khác
hoặc là giống như tôi làm ở ở trường tôi
là đổi cái này phải đổi luôn cái ở dưới
người dùng Tránh hiểu nhầm chứ Nếu mà
bây giờ giả sử là đấy
Lúc đầu điểm danh lớp này nhưng ấn sửa
lớp này xong giờ ấn điểm danh thì Rốt
cuộc là người dùng nó sẽ hiểu muốn điểm
danh con lớp nào đúng không ạ Đấy
còn bây giờ tôi đang làm hệ thống dễ thì
sẽ là kiểu lớp mà mình đã chọn thì mình
sẽ điểm danh một lớp đấy thôi thì mình
sẽ chuyển trong cái form này này mình sẽ
truyền thêm một cái nữa là input
2D
và nêm sẽ là subject à code ID đúng
không ạ
Mình sẽ vào luôn nó chính là
đi luôn
sắp chết ID luôn
mình sẽ chuyển lên hai cái này để mình
hiểu được là mình sẽ điểm danh cho lớp
và môn nào
truyền lên ở đây có những cái như này
một cái quan trọng nữa đó là mình sẽ
truyền lên Nếu thấy ở đây mình sẽ truyền
lên cái cái mảng started Tôi sẽ đặt tên
cái này nó sẽ lên hiểu nó số nhiều như
này
mình sẽ chuyển lên một cái status như
thế này nó là mạng
không xem nha
thiên đình
và thằng này tôi sẽ truyền đây là router
danh này
đó mấy ông sẽ thấy là cái thằng 1 8 9 ở
đây sẽ tương đương với ID mã của thằng
Sinh viên
là 18 và 9 đúng không ạ Đấy ở đây mình
sẽ truyền lên thêm cái ca đúng không ạ
Bây giờ mình chỉ đơn giản thôi rất là
đơn giản mình sẽ có status app ở đây sẽ
có là student
và
tại Status như thế này luôn Mình sẽ lưu
lại trong cái thằng mua đồ
tenden này mình sẽ crash ở đây Mình sẽ
lưu lại nó là với từng thằng này mình sẽ
lưu lại là mình sẽ có
à quên quên mình sẽ phải
Lưu lại attender trước đã
Hình như lại có sai đi này
có xe đi này
sắp check ID này
nay thì sẽ là nào cũng được Hoặc là nếu
mà ông muốn cho chuẩn hơn thì ông sẽ là
Dead ở đây em ăn đây này
sau đó thì lưu lại điểm danh chi tiết
Mình sẽ lưu lại vào
mình sẽ có từ thằng attender này
ID này mình sẽ truyền tên ID chuyển vào
trong này Đấy và tiếp theo mình sẽ có to
lên ID
sẽ bằng sự đề này đi này và sau tết
xong
tôi làm đoạn này rất là nhanh vì tôi
hiểu được nghiệp vụ rồi
mới đăng thêm cho mình chưa cập nhật đại
có thể đã Đợi tí nhé mình sẽ có
feble
những Hải Sang đúng không ạ
hai cột
ok ok
tại trang này
chọn lại đi học
như này ấn điểm danh Ok Đấy
mẹ tôi vừa làm xong cái đồ
đến điểm danh của ông cái phân khó nhất
chưa đầy một tiếng đúng không ạ làm rất
là nhanh Bởi tôi hiểu được phải làm gì
được chưa đó Bây giờ mình cái nó khó hơn
cái này mới gọi cái khó hơn là bây giờ
ông điểm danh xong rồi Đương nhiên bây
giờ tôi sẽ quay trở lại cái trang vừa
rồi quay trở lại trang vừa rồi tôi sẽ
dùng robot
cái quan trọng đây nhưng đó là Ờ bây giờ
hiển thị lại đúng cái mà đã điểm danh
thì nó như thế nào quan trọng như thế
thì sẽ returnect
nếu mà hình như mình sẽ kiểu tương bác
rồi vậy
tránh nhé
bác bây giờ hết của tôi rồi
đâu nhỉ tế à Thực tế là mấy ông nên làm
bạn đấy bằng Ajax chứ không cần tải lại
trang các thứ như thế nó đỡ phải điều
hướng quay trở lại rồi Kiểu như này
là hay để mà làm cái trò này đó ông đầy
thẳng lên thanh địa chỉ khi mà ông chọn
xong cái form đầy thẳng lên hay địa chỉ
ông lấy về nó sẽ đỡ khó chịu hơn nó sẽ
như này
tuy rất đều hướng về nó dễ nữa cũng sẽ
là để đây là cos
rất là dễ ông sẽ chỉ cần ghi đi Rex
đến cái router
Index
trong trường hợp mà
ông này
cái cái tôi đang làm nó là gì là
tôi kiểm tra nếu trong trường hợp trống
nghĩa là trong trường hợp là null viết
kiểu này viết tắt nếu trong trường hợp
null thì tôi sẽ lấy lấy từ trong cái
form để tôi lấy ra đấy Cái cách viết
kiểu như này thay vì ông sẽ kiểu ít null
ở đây này
ông sẽ phải kiểu khi rất dài dòng như
này
Nếu mà có code sẽ đi thì mình sẽ lấy có
xe đi không thì như này không không phải
làm thế này sẽ thêm viết tắt hơn viết
tắt kiểu như này thôi
đó ok chưa
cái mẹo mẹo nữa chỉ cho
này lớp 1 xong rồi môn này môn cuối đúng
không Thì tôi ấn điểm danh xong thì tôi
ấn điểm danh xong thì nó sẽ điều hướng
quay trở lại đúng cái lớp và môn này cho
mấy ông xem
danh danh
cái form này router
tại sao rồi kệ a thender này đang bị
nhầm nó sao mà có xe đi nếu mà ông khai
báo kiểu như này thì nó sẽ hiểu được là
Tender này cũng có thể là một cái mã như
này đấy Hồi trước tôi bị cái lỗi kiểu
như này Bây giờ mình sẽ đặt tên hàng
ngày mình lên như thế này gạch chéo được
để tránh tránh để hiểu là 22 nó không
chung với nhau rất là dị
rồi ok đó Bây giờ nó mới nhảy này Tắt
bớt mấy đống này đi này
lại any cái any rất là hay Nghĩa là nó
có thể any nó vừa là post vừa là ghét
được Rất tiện ở trong trường hợp mà tôi
khi mà truyền cái mã lớp và mã môn lên
thanh địa chỉ rồi thì tôi không cần phải
nó là forbes nữa
nó sẽ chuyển như này mã môn là mã lớp là
một mà mở lớp mạ mom là năm nó sẽ lấy
lại được đúng cái lớp và môn tôi đã chọn
đúng không ạ ok chưa Đây là một cái mẹo
khi mà ông muốn điều hướng quay lại và
và ông muốn truyền cái tham số để quay
lại đấy Kiểu như thế ông có thể truyền
trong ông có thể truyền trong system
cũng được một trong hai cách Còn nếu
không làm tốt hơn thì ông sẽ dùng Isaac
đoạn này để đỡ phải truyền
này cũng tốt
sẽ lấy ngày hôm nay là chủ đây đúng
không ạ là Tết
đây
mình sẽ lấy theo đúng cái lớp và môn
mình đã chọn thôi
đây lấy nó ra nếu mà
nếu mà có như này
điểm danh thì sao quan trọng như thế thì
mình sẽ cần phải cẩu
bản chất ở đây nha bạn chất đây nó là
vẫn là mạng hai chiều nó sẽ bao gồm mình
mình sẽ lấy điểm danh chi tiết của những
cái sinh viên có thể ra bởi vì mấy ông
nên nhớ là vừa nãy chỉ có chỉ có mỗi ba
thằng đầu được điểm danh thôi đúng không
ạ Mình lưu lại mỗi 3 thằng đầu thôi đấy
thôi đúng không Mình sẽ có mạng hai
chiều sẽ theo mã của sinh viên để hiển
thị ra ở đây mình sẽ có một mạng như này
Đầu tiên thì cứ mặc định cho cái mảng
này chống đã
nếu mà có thì đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ cần
lấy toàn bộ điểm danh của sinh viên kia
bằng athendant to đình mình sẽ
quay đi này sau đó thì đơn giản là que
nằm trong cái ID kia thôi
lấy lấy cái này ra thôi Tôi nghĩ là cái
đoạn này làm tắt hơn thì mình sẽ vào
thẳng ngày cho nhanh này lấy mỗi ID này
ở đây mình sẽ chỉ cần kiểm tra là nếu mà
nó không trống MT đi
tôi sẽ lấy hết để lấy toàn bộ Lấy toàn
bộ ra
để toàn bộ ra ở đây sẽ bao gồm cả
mình sẽ lấy ra cái gì mình sẽ lấy ra từ
đường ID
và
status tình trạng đi học của nó đấy
Và bây giờ mình sẽ ở đây sẽ có forex ở
đây
mình sẽ có mình sẽ truyền vào trong cái
thằng status này này
như này cho mình xem nhé
nghĩa là có ba sinh viên được điểm danh
rồi thì sẽ là tình trạng đi học của nó
là đi học và nghỉ nghỉ đúng không ạ 1 2
2 chuẩn chưa
mình sẽ truyền cái mảng này sang bên này
đó Thế là xong bên này bên này thì mình
sẽ làm như sau cái này thì đến cái đoạn
status này này đến cái đoạn status này
mình sẽ kiểm tra là nếu mà
ít
satos tại cái student ID
Tại thằng sư đường ID này
nếu mà có ít ics nếu có IC này nếu có
này
nếu có đã nhé Đấy sau đó thì ông mới
kiểm tra tiếp là ít ở đây đi ít ít
đương nhiên là hạn chế nên xử lý ở cái
đoạn Panel như này nhưng mà về cơ bản
mình cũng chạy vòng lặp để duyệt nên tôi
nghĩ là đoạn này Thực ra cũng được không
bị lỗi
và cái status này này
nó bằng bằng bằng bằng bằng 1 ra bằng
một như thế này
thì mình sẽ trích kịch đó rồi
đó thấy lên đi học không Thế xong rồi
đấy đội nó bằng 2 là xong
OK chưa
là người dùng dễ hiểu là cập nhật chứ
không phải là là thêm đúng không ạ thêm
nó sẽ bị báo lỗi ngay đúng chứ
nhé
đây mình sẽ không rết nữa mà mình sẽ ở
đây mình sẽ bao gồm là
là mình sẽ kiểm tra và
thực tế là cái môn này có thể thay đổi
cơ
chung là kiểm tra kiểm tra xem là đã
lớp lớp và môn chính xác chỉ cần lớp và
môn và ca đấy thôi tồn tại là đủ rồi
ở đây là sẽ là
kiểm tra ba thằng này trước này phốt này
như này ít
này
thì mình mới bắt đầu
Red để mà Insert nó
và mình sẽ truyền thêm thằng sắp chết ID
như thế này mới đúng
cùng ca đấy cùng ngày hôm đấy và cùng ca
đấy thì rõ ràng à Không được phép dùng
rồi đấy
điểm danh thì
rồi còn đoạn này
như thế này
lại sẽ kiểm tra là nếu mà
có buổi điểm danh hôm đấy rồi Và nếu có
sinh viên đấy rồi thì mình sẽ chỉ cập
nhật điểm danh thôi tình trạng đi học
thôi chứ mình không Insert nữa nó sẽ như
này ok chưa Tại trông có vẻ hơi phức tạp
một tí nhé Để tôi nói lại nhé Cái này
Đầu tiên là kiểm tra xem là lớp đấy ngày
hôm đấy ca đấy đã học hay chưa đúng
không ạ Nó bỏ qua cả môn luôn bởi rõ
ràng là tôi bảo rồi ba cái này mới là ba
cái kiểm tra tránh trùng thôi đấy đúng
không ạ Nếu mà nếu mà chưa đúng không ạ
nếu trong trường hợp Nếu chưa thì mình
tạo mới đúng không ạ Mình sẽ khi tạo mới
xong mình sẽ có ID để mình sẽ in search
vào và bây giờ mình sẽ kiểm tra là nếu
mà nếu mà
cùng buổi điểm danh đấy sinh viên đấy đã
tạo chưa Nếu mà nếu mà chưa thì sẽ tạo
đây cái hàm creator update này rất là
hay nó sẽ kiểm tra hai cái thằng này
thôi Nếu mà chưa có thì tạo Còn nếu mà
có rồi thì sẽ update update mỗi trường
này đó
nhầm nhầm
sao thấy sai sai
nó phải quay lại lớp 1 năm lớp 1 năm
Đợi tí Đợi tí Tại sao tạo một ít đường
mới nhỉ vẫn ngày hôm nay mà qua ngày đâu
À rồi rồi rồi rồi rồi rồi k2k2
[âm nhạc]
ra cái đoạn này đang bị nhược điểm mấy
ông đang thấy cái hiển thị Đang hiển thị
cái mặc định thì nó đang hiển thị K1
Thế mình sẽ như thế mình sẽ phải chơi
trò này nữa để chắc chắn nó hiển thị ra
ca mà mình vừa mới Insert đúng không ạ
là mình sẽ phải là đây sẽ là
Order by ra giả sử là kiểu hôm đấy điểm
danh cả 2k và mình sẽ chỉ hiển thị cái
ca gần nhất trong ngày hôm nay thôi thì
nó sẽ như thế này
chưa Ok chưa đây trong trường hợp mà ông
cho một lớp học đi học kiểu Môn đấy rồi
2k liền trong một ngày thực tế ở trường
tôi không làm cái trò đấy Không có
trường hợp này xảy ra đấy nhưng mấy ông
vừa thấy tôi đã hiển thị ra được đúng
các thứ thứ rồi đúng không ạ cho mỗi hai
thằng cuối này nhé Cho vẫn là cả hai đi
Ấn update này Ok Hiển thị ra ok chưa
chọn lại chọn lại môn đấy
ra Ok chứ ngon chưa
đấy tôi đã làm xong cho mấy ông về điểm
danh và điểm danh chi tiết nó sẽ bao gồm
kiểu xử lý như thế này code có tầm trăm
dòng chứ mấy
toán ở đây Thực ra nó không hẳn là khó
lắm cái khó nhất là làm việc với mảng
nhiều chiều thì tôi đã chỉ cho mấy ông ở
đoạn này đây mạng chỉ hai chiều thôi
cũng chưa hẳn là nhiều chiều lắm đâu
từng làm mảng ba bốn chiều Nhưng mà thực
ra khi mà Ông làm được mảng một hai
chiều rồi thực ra là mấy ông về sau mạng
nhiều chiều bao nhiêu chiều nữa vẫn chơi
được đấy
Ok chưa mấy ông có thắc mắc gì đoạn nào
không thắc mắc thì tôi cứ mặc định là
mấy ông hiểu rồi nhé
tôi chữa luôn à
ông xem video để hình Dung để hiểu thôi
xong rồi mấy ông sẽ phải làm lại đấy
liệu toàn bộ sinh viên đúng không sau đó
hiển thị điểm danh Nếu có chứ
lấy điểm danh kiểm tra xem có điểm danh
chưa nếu có rồi thì hiển thị ra xong rồi
Điền vào chỗ trống thôi đúng không
cái thứ không khuyến khích ở đâu nhé
thắc mắc gì thì hôm nay chúng ta sẽ tạm
nghỉ
tạm nghỉ thế thôi còn
chấm đồ án thì mấy ông cứ tiếp tục làm
xong rồi buổi sau tôi sẽ chấm Ok chưa